على كل اني ينضم الينا من القاهره المرشد
احمد العمري احمد اهلا بك مساء الخير شكرا
معنا في مساء العربيه اولا كيف كان شعورك
يعني بعد المقطع الفيديو اللي صورته وانت
تنشد لك كل هذا الاعجاب والتفاعل ليس في
مصر بس ولكن حتى في الوطن العربي
الفل عليكم
اول حاجه كل سنه وانتم طيبين
وبفضل الله انا ما كنتش اعرف ان الفيديو
هينال اثره وكده ومش اعرف ان الموضوع كان
بالنسبه لي مفاجاه انا من زمان بصور
فيديوهات
ولكن يعني يمكن ربنا عوض لي تعب سنين اللي
فاتت في فيديو دلوقتي الحمد لله طب يا
استاذ احمد استاذ احمد اليوم اذا بدنا
نحكي عن منشد في مصر ومنشد حقق جماهيريه
كبيره في الداخل المصري وحتى في الخارج
بمن تاثرت من كان ملهمك في الانشاد
[موسيقى]
رحمه الله عليه طبعا فضيله الشيخ سيد
نقشبندي انا كنت يعني متاثر به جدا ويعني
الشيخ سمك شبندي كان بالنسبه لي هو مش
منشد فقط انا بتعلم منه هو بالنسبه لي
اب روحي ليا لان انا كنت بقعد دايما اسمعو
كنت بتاثر به وببكي وبحس ان انا بسمعه
متعلق بيه ان هو قريب مني يعني رحمه الله
عليه يعني رحمه الله عليه طيب في شروط
لازم تتوفر بالمنشد يا احمد يعني امام
مثلا كثره المنشدين اليوم
طبعا المنشد لازم يكون عنده موهبه كامله
هو هبه متكامله الموهبه المتكامله هي
مساحه الصوت والاحساس والنغم وبعد كده
يثقل الموهبه ديت بالتعلم والدراسه والروح
طبعا لازم الاهتمام بجانب الروح لان الروح
ده مش بيجي من يومه ليله بيجي عن طريق حب
الحب الحقيقي لسيدنا النبي والصحابه وال
البيت وربنا سبحانه وتعالى فلازم موضوع
المنشد الحته الانشاديه يمكن صعبه شويه عن
الحته الترابيه مش صعبه شويه ده هي في فرق
بينها وبين الحته الترابيه يعني مسافات
كبيره جدا
جدا ولازم حتى نفهم اكثر ممكن نسمع منك
شيء مولاي مثلا نقشبندي
يلا يلا بينا
بنوري وجهك اني
وجل ومن يعز بك لن يشقى الى
[موسيقى]
الابد
مهما لقيت من الدنيا
وعارضها
فانت لي شغل عم
ا
يواجه جسدي
تحلو
مراره
عيش
في رض
اك تحلو مراره عيش في رضاك في ر
تحلو مراره
عيش في رضاك ولا
اطيق
سخطا على
عيش من
[موسيقى]
الله يا احمد مولاي اني ببابك شكرا لك
شكرا جزيلا يا احمد